es ist kalt und matschig und regnerisch
und ungemütlich draußen aber wenn es
euch so geht wie mir dann seid ihr
wahrscheinlich schon total scharf darauf
erste gemüse auszusehen und damit kann
man im februar tatsächlich schutz
anfangen sowohl im freiland draußen als
auch drinnen für die jungpflanzen
anzucht und in diesem video verrate ich
euch welche gemüse man im februar schon
sehen kann falls nämlich noch nicht
kennst ich bin marie ich poste jeden
samstag immer um 10 uhr morgens ein
neues video und um die themen
selbstversorgung aus dem garten und
gemüsegarten habe ich ganz viele
spannende gartentipps für euch geplant
dieses jahr und damit du kein video mehr
verpasst doch mal den abo button und
auch die glocke dann bekommst du nämlich
immer eine benachrichtigung sobald das
neue video online ist aber dafür machen
wir uns mal lieber hier gemütlich auf
dem sofa draußen ist es nämlich wirklich
sehr sehr ungemütlich heute und fange
mal an mit dem pflanzen die man jetzt
schon im haus vorziehen kann nummer eins
ist die artischocke artischocken kann
man auch in deutschland oder auch in
österreich im freilandanbau das ist eine
mehrjährige pflanze die sache ist dass
man manchmal probleme hat sie zu
überwintern wir hatten schon
artischocken die erfroren sind im winter
wir hatten genau so auch artischocken
die es geschafft haben und leider tragen
artischocken erst im zweiten und dritten
jahr richtig üppig es gibt einige
einzelne pflanzen die auch schon im
ersten jahr blüten bilden man ist ja die
knospen der artischocken aber leider
klappt das nicht mit allen pflanzen wir
hatten es so dass ungefähr die hälfte
der pflanzen im ersten jahr schon
getragen haben und dann muss man die im
winter vor dem winter einmal über dem
boden abschneiden und dick mit stroh
münchen und hoffen dass es warm genug
ist damit die artischocken überwintern
können das hilft natürlich die an einen
geschützten ort zu pflanzen aber wenn du
artischocken in deinem garten
ausprobieren möchtet dann ist jetzt ein
super zeitpunkt um die im haus
vorzuziehen ein anderes gemüse dass du
jetzt vorziehen kannst es der blumenkohl
da habe ich zwei sollten die ich super
gerne anbau die sind beide auch für so
früh raus sagten geeignet dass es einmal
die sorte er vortags werk und dann die
sorte neckar perle die kann man jetzt
auch super gut im haus vorziehen
blumenkohl ist auch so ein gemüse dass
ich immer erst mal in größere schalen
aussehe mit ganz vielen pflanzen und
dann begierig die in einzel
köpfchen chilis sind auch geeignet für
so früh raus sagten die brauchen immer
sehr lange um in die partie zu kommen
also wenn du im sommer chilis ernten
möchtest dann ist jetzt ein super
zeitpunkt um die auszusehen das könnte
man auch schon im januar machen ich
fange erst im februar an weil ich ja nur
doch arg früh finde aber anfang februar
ist doch ein sehr sehr guter zeitpunkt
um chilis auszusehen noch so eine kleine
schneise im gemüsegarten ist der
knollensellerie den sehe ich auch im
februar aus im haus um ihn dann später
aus zu pflanzen
die pflanze ich immer mit in meine
gebete kohl laub und sellerie packe ich
immer zusammen in ein beet war das eine
ganz tolle mischkultur ist und weil
sellerie so langsam wächst ist jetzt
auch ein sehr guter zeitpunkt um mit der
vorhand sucht anzufangen eine ganz tolle
knolle sellerie sorte die wir immer
wieder anbauen und die wir sehr lieben
ist die sorte monarch dies auch nicht so
runzelig außen also schon irgendwie hund
zulegt die sind alle irgendwie klotzig
und komisch oder wände ist so eine
komische plan für eine sehr hässliche
pflanzen welche libyen drin aber die
sorte monarchie ist er glatt außen so
dass man dann in der küche später nicht
mehr so viel arbeit hat beim putzen und
sauber machen das geht natürlich auch
für stangensellerie auch der kann jetzt
schon im haus vorgezogen werden ich habe
übrigens einen kostenlosen medicus für
euch erstellt das gewisse daten gut
kennen da könnt ihr euch gerne für
anmelden der dinge ist unten in der
video beschreibung da zeige ich euch vom
beete anlegen über die außer bis hin zu
meinen besten zeit tipps im hochsommer
um ein drei phasen garten system das das
ganze system das ich selber entwickelt
habe nach dem gärtnern und das es
ermöglicht bei einem minimum an aufwand
richtig gutes gemüse anzubauen also
meldet euch gerne an der weg ist wie
gesagt in der video beschreibung da
entsteht auch um eine gastrolle
gemeinschaft aus ganz vielen
gartenfreunden die sich gegenseitig
unterstützen inspirieren tipps geben das
ist immer eine ganz tolle sache ich
freue mich auf jeden fall wenn ihr dabei
seid kohlrabi kann man so früh um ja
auch schon aussehen ich sehe da so früh
im jahr am liebsten die sorte lange das
ist eine sehr frühe sorte für eine sehr
frühe ernte
ansonsten gibt es auch noch es daher
glaube ich dass es so ein wunderschöner
lila kohlrabi und die sorte super
schmelz ist auch super lecker macht sehr
schöne zarte
riesengroße knollen ein weiteres gemüse
dass du jetzt schon vorziehen kannst ist
laut da empfehle ich immer für die
sommerernte die sorte hillary und für
die winter ernte die sollte blaugrüner
winter das sind zwei sehr sehr tolle
sorten den einlauf kann man dann eben
ernten so lange es noch warm ist und
dann soweit es kalt wird wird dann der
andere läuft eher ein bisschen langsamer
wächst und sehr viel frost empfindlicher
ist der blau-grüne winter erntereif
paprika sind jetzt auch fällig also wenn
du deine eigenen paprika ziehen möchtest
dann ist jetzt ein sehr guter zeitpunkt
paprika sind auch eher langsam
tomaten würde ich jetzt noch nicht aus
allen im februar aus sah man wie sehr
früh ins gewächshaus pflanzen und hatte
in der geschützten standort wo die dann
auch vor mitte mai gepflanzt werden
könnten ansonsten würde ich mit tomaten
jetzt noch warten aber bei paprika so
viel länger brauchen
wer jetzt im februar auch ein sehr guter
zeitpunkt um die auszusehen eine tolle
und sehr freiland geeignete sorte die
ich euch empfehlen kann ist die sorte
neu sieht der ideal als rotkohl kann man
jetzt auch wunderbar im haus vorziehen
und auch salat beim salat ist eher
schwierig um die jahreszeit total auf
einen winter salat sollte die nicht
sichtbar kann ich nochmal die einblenden
back ist eine tolle winter salatsorten
wir bauen den im freiland im winter an
und ernten dann den ganzen winter über
von einem beet dass wir im herbst mit
diesem salat einsehen bis in den april
hinein immer unseren frischen salat ein
weiteres gemüse dass du jetzt schon
vollziehen kannst ist weißkohl vor allem
die frühen sorten da kann ich euch die
sorte nagels früh weiß empfehlen die
sorgt dann dafür dass man im frühsommer
dann schon die ersten köpfe ernten kann
die sollten für das sauerkraut und für
die herbst ernte die ein bisschen
langsamer wachsen
die sehe ich eher ein bisschen später
aus also da fange ich jetzt noch nicht
mit der vor anzucht an
außerdem kannst du auch wir sehen jetzt
schon aussehen besonders die frühen
schnell wachsenden sorten die man dann
im sommer enden möchte für den winter
irgendwie sehen würde da er noch ein
bisschen warten mit der aussaat wenn ihr
mein video zu den häufigsten fehlern bei
der jungpflanzen an sucht noch nicht
gesehen habt dann verlinke ich euch das
mal hier oben da solltet ihr auf jeden
fall mal reinschauen da gibt es nämlich
einiges was man falsch machen kann wenn
man pflänzchen im haus vorziehen will
jetzt reden wir aber weiter
über die pflanzen die man im
gemüsegarten aussehen kann das sind
leider nicht ganz so viele aber man kann
schon einige kandidaten jetzt draußen
aussehen es kommt natürlich immer so ein
bisschen aufs wetter an also wenn es
super super kalt ist bei euch und jetzt
wochenlange frost angekündigt ist dann
heißt es noch ein bisschen warten aber
bei uns hat es zum beispiel jetzt schon
wochenlang keinen frost mehr gegeben es
ist kein frost angekündigt deswegen
mache ich jetzt schon die ersten
aussagen sind zwar nur hat eine handvoll
gemüse die man jetzt schon aussehen kann
aber dann muss man eben auch früher mit
der ernte dran wenn man jetzt schon
auswählen kann eines der allerersten
gemüse die man im frühling in seinem
garten serien kann oder jetzt auch im
februar sehen kann sind erbsen und
zuckererbsen sind dann noch ein bisschen
frost unempfindlicher als die anderen
ärzten typen die so gibt eine ganz tolle
zucker ärzten sorte ist die sorte
ambrosia die ist wirklich zuckersüß und
super lecker also gerade wenn du mit
kindern gärten als würde ich immer immer
immer ärzten anbau und die kinder in
unserer nachbarschaft und auch mein sohn
lieben es immer die ersten weg zu
schnupfen ich krieg da immer kaum was ab
sie sagen immer die schmecken passt so
gut wie bonbon ist auch dicke boden kann
man jetzt schon ins freiland säen
ich mache das immer lieber im herbst
davor weil ich die erfahrung gemacht
habe dass dicke bohnen die auf dem beet
über winter die sind relativ frosthart
dass die im nächsten jahr weniger von
der schwarzen bohnen ausgefallen werden
man kann aber auch wunderbar jetzt im
frühling dicke bodensee das sind mit die
frühesten kandidaten die jetzt schon
gehen was ich jetzt auch schon
ausgewählt habe sind möhren die decke
ich um diese jahreszeit immer mit einem
vlies ab damit es noch ein bisschen
wärmer haben dann kommen die schneller
da wär ich um die jahreszeit immer die
sorte gonzenheimer treibt das ist eine
sehr schnell wachsende und kälte
unempfindliche möhre die etwas kleinere
oder größere wurzeln bildet aber dafür
eine frühere ernte
übrigens habe ich ein video gemacht 25
raketen gewesen die ruckzuck erntereif
sind das verlinkt ich euch nochmal hier
oben
gemüse die ich davor stelle könnt ihr
jetzt schon in ihrem garten anbauen und
dann hoffentlich ganz alten erste ernte
einbahn ein weiteres gemüse das jetzt
auch schon geht sind radieschen die habe
ich draußen jetzt auch schon ausgewählt
da empfehle ich euch die sollte so rack
oder zur auf weiß nicht genau so hart zu
ruhig nochmal hier ein und die spieler
als spieler habe ich auch schon gesät in
dieser kühlen jahreszeit da brauche ich
immer am liebsten die sorte winter
riesen anfangs noch keinen pflanzt land
der im gemüsegarten erstellt das dann
zeige ich dir hier drücken wie das geht
darum findest du auch noch entspannen im
video schlecht sehen wir uns ja das ist
klar
[Musik]